free if we battle overpopulation by
having fewer children
how will we support the resulting larger
population of old people well I don't
know I mean I know how about taxing me
yeah I don't pay enough yeah I'm willing
to probably pay more taxes yeah I think
it's right and also we don't live in an
age and people and people want to work
longer to I mean in terms of retirement
people don't want to retire at the same
time anymore I'm gonna step down at 95
so I can learn how to play golf
that's also I mean the the tax dollars
are are sort of unfairly sent to the
older half of the population it's the
children and you know me I'm not a
children lover but I mean even I can
read the paper
it's a children or shatter old people
because they vote because old people
vote in big numbers right children don't
vote I mean you look at a lot of these
state budgets and intimately familiar
with California really at the end of the
day if you distill it down it is a
budget about next generation or really
our agent ingrain population I mean
fundamentally the discretionary budgets
that's the choice and that's not kind of
choice I think anyone pretty good Excel
right however once they're mean you
don't want to touch the throw wrap the
question out even like let's get off
this right now I love the old people and
they're okay Tracy what is on your
knitting needle right now ms sweater for
my cutter for my husband a card of yeah
I'm still knitting god I mean you know
you know when you've hit menopause you
just pick up some needles and start
throwing back oh it's hot this knitting
by the way Tracy my wife was a great
great knitter and you know what she's
doing
it's very curious you've seen tea cozies
she's knitting a cozy for the entire
house it drapes over the whole thing
that's brilliant not in Kashmir cuz that
be I'm not an expert
I don't know what it is but just areal
watch thank you mom
do you think Obama cookies mother
impossible most of the people on that
show don't come from New Jersey I was
just speaking to no I was just speaking
in New Jersey and they're so ashamed of
that show they can hardly speak like the
only thing only one of the people who's
supposed to be as Italian is really
Italian right you know it's I mean it's
it swelled up it's about product but I
think some of them are a time the
situation yeah I like when they say
great literally all the realism of skin
look for more realism from our from our
MTV reality shows on the it's not a
reality show no but it might as well be
it's my understanding but to be fair
vicina I'm slightly above the skin's age
bracket and so I've mainly read about
skins in News Weekly
okay because you know when it first was
coming out there was articles in the
paper and some of it one of my friends
he met so you gotta watch the show it's
nothing but kids [ __ ] I've watched it
there's no kids [ __ ] it's actually
not a bad show it's actually kind of sad
the kids cuz it's about what you know
what goes on with kids and they're like
they're so alienated that they pop pills
and you know they need guidance from an
older or father figure
[Laughter]
please will never like that kids like
that
why do you think the Republican
presidential candidates are taking so
much time to announce that they are
running well Obama's poll numbers are
weirdly high ya know and money I mean
this is I mean your daughter I don't
think it's unsound 500 pounds she had to
raise a lot of money but it's absurd I
mean you're talking close to a billion
dollars these campaign he's a great
nation great problems we didn't he'd get
more money at this point he or she if
you if you come in first you get more
money yeah you know this a lot better
you start but you know I can't read your
earn rate I usually start spending that
money in states and so you end up just
spending it and throwing it down and so
I yeah I mean fundamentally it's a money
thing and they're trying to tactically
figure out where Obama's gonna be and
the best place to put them is on the
defense when it comes to the economy how
do you do that you go forward with
aggressive budget cuts which will slow
down GDP growth which is exactly what
Connell and everyone else it was good
news today good candidates this is a
problem that Obama is a he is a
masterful politician you know we all
complain about him on though if he's not
doing it I think if you're inside his
head what he would say is it's very
simple guys I know exactly how much
political capital I have when it gets up
to here I spend some like he did with
the marriage the perfect example and
he's like tacked back but when my bank
account a political capital is above 50
I'll spend some but when it's down here
that's gonna spend it you got it - all
right thank you everybody thank you
panelists
[Applause]